gang quick update on the middle class
famous tour we're going to be coming to
the moon tower comedy festival that's
austin baby teja april 22nd and 23rd
april 22nd we're going to be doing an
evening with ru garbage that's our
stand-up show and then we play a little
ayg with the crowd yes best news is it's
open to the public get your tickets
link's gonna be in the description you
get them on the moon tower comedy
festival website find the link get the
tickies then the next night we're doing
a live ru garbage podcast recording with
a guest to be determined it's gonna be
good get your tickets that austin let's
go broncos welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out the girl to be classy yeah
that's just a big old piece of trash
trash trash trash i'm your host holy
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here in aunt toddy's basement she
has filed her first
cease and desist order i like this judge
judy who are we talking against you whoa
for buying any more of those dumbass
jackets
little shot at the boss right after
payday ladies and gentlemen my co-host
is coming at you from across the table
he's the new knight rider coming out to
cbs this fall yeah
very powerful man in show business sure
get a table in any restaurant in this
city any mickey d's below 14. she
brought us out of gallagher's on on a
wednesday at seven he couldn't pull that
off
could you kevin james you're still upset
about that so you've actually we've been
fighting for the best i'm over there
eating it frankie and johnny's like a
[ __ ] jerk off
you celebrating anything what yeah my
ged [ __ ] you should be a [ __ ]
martini you shouldn't be celebrating
that we're here because we're the only
goddamn table
at dinner time what the [ __ ] going on
that seafood wasn't fresh i think man
you're
that [ __ ] ain't fresh we have to get out
of the trash we'll be right back gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are true
roof cooking and then patreon.com we are
closing in on our next goal it's in the
sites the ten thousand dollar roulette
one spin that i'm still quite upset
about it's coming up at a real bad time
oh the big man yeah the big man's behind
the eight ball oh we got a new variant
coming out shut this thing down for a
couple months
[Laughter]
uh guys join patreon.com i get a [ __ ]
ton there's a there's over a hundred
bonus episodes between hard feelings ayg
we do live streams it's a [ __ ] good
time also new michelob jacket there you
go
good time over there on the patreon
we're having fun over there yeah it is
going to be skit skating around the
country a little bit too yeah we're
going to be doing a lot we're going to
be doing some more uh hard feelings in
the car stuff like that stuff on the
road stuff from the airbnb just you know
kind of really take that i mean we
really let it all hang out like see me
poolside yeah we give you the inside
look as is but we're really dropping all
the uh dropping trout i'm offering full
frontal nudity on the patreon god dude
it's literally only a matter of time
can't see nothing anyway what's the
matter you trying to think i'm wearing a
baiting shirt
don't have to spend any money on
pixelization my little guy stays in the
pool house you know what i mean
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good graduate of the
stellar adler academy of fine arts give
it up for t-bone mcstuffins toby
mcbutton i see foley's over there
[Laughter]
dude he's gonna call him god
check out the patreon if you want to
know what the backstory on that is how
you feeling big guy i'm feeling great
it's great to sit down with the head
coach of iceland from the mighty ducks
too this guy's a pretty good villain by
the way that's pretty good you're both
gonna be very upset with me so are the
younger demographics out there your bozo
uh generation i don't know why you're
attacking me so much this episode
because i don't like you i don't like
your face all right finally i took 287
episodes for it to come out
your hair's growing at an incredible
rate too pretty good it looked
you had like a fresh haircut like a
couple days ago and now you look like a
weekend
how do you sold your soul to the dude
you're getting the illuminati or
something like that
chewing up endochrome to get to get the
fade back yeah chewing on umbilical
cords and [ __ ] get those [ __ ] stem
cells in me
i go right to the source hey doc hook me
up
let me get 2 for 20 out the back chasing
oils around the city
that's foreskin
whatever i'll take it ah
it's the grossest but most effective
every once in a while why i'll say i
hate something uh-huh toby will say uh
movies tv shows
well let's let's pull back a half you
hate everything you don't know right
away you hate it i don't like pluto's
got a real problem i hate this person
and then you meet the part that guy's
[ __ ] fantastic she's the best that
show's good that movie's good sure
vegetables aren't that bad what do you
got
not in this case unfortunately and i
apologize i went into with an open heart
um
i'm 10 years older than you guys when
mighty ducks came out i was in high
school 92 to grunge was big i was
you know what i mean i was chasing the
tail around yeah getting shoved in
lockers and [ __ ] jerking off man
across stick
um so i didn't like it you guys are big
fans of it i sat down i watched mighty
dogs i mean okay
i didn't like it you're [ __ ] 50 years
old it was made in the 90s for eight
year olds of course you're not gonna
like it thought the acting was suspect
the script was okay i don't know what
was going on with the production design
but emilio pulled through
i guess bombay you're going to sit here
and disrespect g bombay what was his
name jordan the other coach wasn't even
that big of a dick
he was all right he was just trying to
teach him teach him right from wrong hey
he's the [ __ ] one that joked not the
coach he's just [ __ ] trying to help
the youth out of that [ __ ]
this has got to be all-time worst take
ever he wasn't that bad of a guy
when i was a kid the bad guys in those
the goonies they're fratelli's they'll
kill you you're comparing it to one
movie
also i'm pretty sure it was a disney
movie i know it was so i mean what's
gonna [ __ ] take him in the locker
room and beat the [ __ ] out of him what
to shove a [ __ ] goalie stick up his
ass it's a [ __ ] disney movie they're
kids god damn it we got to win this game
that coach murdered my entire family
yeah listen yeah listen dude if you
don't make this shoot out i'm going to
[ __ ] kill your dad
and then the old man who [ __ ]
sharpens your skates he's going to
hanzo's i didn't like him at all i think
his name's hans that was the bad guy
from [ __ ] lethal weapon 2. yeah now i
wasn't buying that i didn't trust him
yeah
that nazi [ __ ]
you know he was on a u-boat to argentina
trust his skate shop innocent old man
yeah then the massage hit squad rolls in
no thank you wasn't a fan made it made
it about three quarters of the way
through it okay i'll tell you who's good
though that little josh jackson
from
the main kid yeah from dawson's creek
yeah obviously breakout star he was
great he was great goldberg was you
watch that was dope goldberg was the
second one the first one now goldberg is
in this one goldberg's in the yeah he's
in all three
yeah three of those they had to run it
what were they in their 30s by the third
one i think they even no well they they
did the one and then the the usa team i
think was the second then d3 ducks squat
together or something
let me just i might have been in 3d
didn't they do a 3d at one point that
knuckle puck came out you had a
different [ __ ] angle shout out to the
knucky puck every [ __ ] every fat kid
who couldn't skate was trying to rip off
the knuckle puck in roller hockey he
catches a dui at dewey drinking
heinekens by the way um driving around
like a z6 500 some piece of [ __ ]
he gets given he's your mom's jeep
my jeep
it's my jeep
he gets a dewy
and that's what he gets he has to go
coach a hockey team they don't even say
that when they set it up just all of a
sudden he drives out on the ice yeah it
sounds like you went into this the real
open mind i did i know
man talk about hate watch and a handful
of eddies yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know what was it i might not
even watch the goddamn thing i don't
know
anywho
i thought two years at the roller
skating palace like what the [ __ ] mighty
ducks trish
okay i mean i don't sure
i don't know yeah i mean i wasn't one of
the producers on it or anything i don't
know why why you're throwing i saw a
special thanks at the end
you're throwing it in my face 20 years
later i'm not throwing it in anybody's
face i'm just telling toby unfortunately
usually his recommendations turn me
around this time it didn't work
i'd be willing to take a second look at
it
it was mainly for the cultural
significance of the shore the zeitgeist
you know
it's uh it's a very popular movie that's
what i understand
okay
more of a slap shot kind of guy
that's a film sure completely different
yeah i mean that'd be like hockey
yeah mystery alaska that's all right who
mystery alaska who's mystery alaska so
wasn't that the name of the movie
with russell crowe when they played the
rangers
pretty sure was mystery alaska at first
i thought you said mr e alaska and i was
like who the [ __ ] is mr e alaska so i
got mr edward alaska so i get my eddies
from
yeah now that's where i score my
northern lights oh that was pretty good
smoking my dubious yeah i don't get that
one but people are clamoring for us to
go up to alaska
no you wouldn't go not [ __ ] anywhere
near the winter how we getting there you
got to take one of those real small
planes okay
talk to you later
a couple people hit us up and like tell
you what you guys i would go just for
the for the [ __ ] trip to alaska i'm
not [ __ ] eating your butt cheek
[ __ ] on some hillside somewhere but
this [ __ ] cherry freak we're not
we're not even
yeah i don't know about those little
johns
i mean they don't they cry you know
whatever it is how long do you think
we'd make it out there
in the tundra in the bush
we mean a motel six in anchorage yeah i
mean yeah it's like i mean we're not
taking a wagon up there we're [ __ ]
we're flying into a city not if the skim
boat goes down or something like that
the skim boat whatever we got to take
together i want to land i want to take
one of those planes that lands in the
water that's out of here that's [ __ ]
classy i probably could you know who
does that george clooney in italy lands
right on the water
like como yeah really i've seen one of
them take off there for you it's like
comb over
really all right
let's get
ugly came in here with an open mind just
like i did mighty ducks yeah
well you've been in a [ __ ] mood since i
got here
uh
happy to be here
great
seems it [ __ ] come in [ __ ] trash
in a class you look like the world's
worst bouncer right now by the way yeah
i'm about to kick you out
i'm about to kick you out cause you're
ruining the vibe in here dude
the mighty ducks became an actual team
correct
yeah the anaheim ducks mighty ducks yeah
i don't know if that was like inc i
don't know does estevez get a nickel of
that what's the deal what's what's he
wetting his beak on it i don't think so
it's [ __ ] up yeah that was a it was a
good movie it's just not for you sure
definitely not for you now i just want i
watch moana i watch all the cars yeah
moana was made now
with but it's still for kids yeah but
that the movies now have to are for kids
and adults i just watched casablanca i
loved it that wasn't for me it was made
in the 40s yeah but that's a classic
film what are you talking about so you
admit you're pretty ducks is not a
classic get out of here
it's a classic child film from the 90s
yes okay
i'll take another look at it i'll do you
a favor
no please don't
i don't want to have this conversation
ever again i'll take a look
i could do a live viewing together on
the patreon i'll watch movies together
popcorn
eddies no snuggle up nope okay hans
almost came in today i didn't want to
really if you don't know hans folks he
is our recent hire here at uh are you
garbage that's that technically he's
more of a shareholder than you that's
true and some sort of will if [ __ ] were
to go down yeah he's the [ __ ] boss's
son
[ __ ] must be nice
[ __ ] what's it called yeah why didn't
you yeah optimism nepotism yeah yeah
uh-huh what were you gonna say it wasn't
right no you said optimism and i was
just gonna make fun of you for a minute
and then you finally got the right
answer
but privatism what private school is he
gonna be going to
probably getting the [ __ ] poor kids
kicked out of school for some [ __ ] he
did yeah yeah i see it right now running
for congress
if everything goes as planned you know
what it means
she doesn't kill a hooker in a couple of
years sure get a hold of his laptop get
a kid keep a clean record he can do
whatever he wants why was he going to
come in i had to introduce him to the
team ah the boys starts bossing me
around
you're sniffing his ass
all right good stuff gang this is a
family episode damn damn we're here
we're circling the wagons we're here
together we're going to be answering
your questions yes from the old patreon
there yes also by the way
get some [ __ ] tickets to the live
show i'm not exactly sure what day this
is dropping but chicago might already be
sold out so get those techies right
now
and rosemont picked a slack up with
rosemont tickets are moving there uh
just get your [ __ ] tickets we're
coming everywhere we're gonna be adding
new dates the whole nine yards can't
wait to see us be over there portilouge
chicago got to a nice dinner out there
we got it we'll have that we'll have a
night off in town it'll be nice well not
a night off we'll have a night in town
be nice
maybe go to a cubbies game cubs will be
playing by then
yeah i don't think so yeah all right i
mean he wants to go to a four-hour
[ __ ] game in the sun and then go do
comedy all night
okay
you barely make it to the shows as it is
you're gonna be walking around the
stadium complaining every ten minutes no
i love baseball
what are you gonna do what you don't
love go beat up some socials you don't
love walking
yeah we don't have to walk in the bay
i'm not playing i'd say i wanted to play
right
do you think you could what are the
chances could i play in a professional
baseball game yeah in right field right
tracking down a ball hundred percent
[Music]
i could handle that you couldn't play
t-ball i didn't say i would be good yeah
i mean i could stand there as well i'm
talking about i'm talking about being cr
you know making a play
maybe maybe i could maybe get something
going what do you think
i don't know i'm gonna be out there in
your sweatpants you're gonna wear a
uniform what are we doing here full
philly fanatic here keeping it real got
the hot dog launcher
you're shooting yourself in the face all
right wear the uniform
now you be out in right field getting
chased by bees
coach there's a hornet's nest out here
i think it's a wasp is that poison ivy
sumac
i can handle that i'd be a real [ __ ] in
the box though i'll tell you that i'd be
batting about 12 feet away from that i
don't want any of that smoke
you're having the hot dog guy for
throwing hot dogs onto the field let me
get through
having the beer guys send them down the
eye let me get two
trade all my equipment for nachos
people in the front row folly where's
your bat
look whoever you've got a huge thing of
i don't know coach
king bozo
if i but if i
was gonna attempt to play one
game of a major league sport it would
have to be right field it would have to
be baseball
i'm not mixing it up in the paint with
[ __ ] those dudes i'll tell you i'm
not playing the nba i sure should oh
you're not oh god tebow write that down
in case he ever does join i wouldn't i
want to hold him to his word that he's
never going to play in the nba i'm sure
[ __ ] not [ __ ] mixing it up on the
[ __ ] front lines of an nfl game jesus
what about you punter or something
actually do the extra point what you
just got to get your foot on the ball no
i'm scared that that was always that
petrified i get so much anxiety every
time they kick a punt your [ __ ] legs
are kicked open your nuts are hanging
down that's a vulnerable position sure
no i wouldn't yeah it would have to be
or you know maybe like water polo or
something get the [ __ ] out of here what
do you mean that's hardy [ __ ] you could
just be the goalie no plus those guys
yeah yeah yeah get a nice set of
swimmies or something kick a nice kick
board no those guys are elbowing and
they're grabbing it you're jolly mucking
under the water you're cello you're well
you're jolly what that's what my mom
used to call it your dick she used to
call it the jolla muckin you're a little
jolly mucking
wow that's weird yeah
hopefully that's not some racist racist
term from the 50s
give that a peek on the goop before you
post this t-bone you have to do a little
snippy snippy but yeah you're jolly
mucking
i don't know what that is i thought
that's what it was called
that's what i was told i the three
sports i think you could legitimately
not be competitive
but but
but do you of course not be competitive
i'm not an idiot
yes you are
i still wouldn't be competitive
uh number one sumo wrestling obviously
i don't think so i think those guys
would run me over
yeah he's not he's big but he's not
athletic those guys are strong they're
they work out even though they're fat
they work out
do you know what i think you would
really dominate in legitimately
skeleton what's that it's like the
bobsledding which just one guy on the
sled face first down the hill gravity
does all the work yeah oh [ __ ] that i
know what you're talking what about the
thing oh the luge
man yeah right you have you'd have to
have like four skis on there yet
for those sled snaps take the flatbed
and curling
curling would be all right
why not i'm not doing that it's [ __ ]
the major league that's what i want
baseball okay philly's right field tell
harper to [ __ ] take take five the big
dog's coming in you're the only guy who
proposes a hypothetical question and
then when phone answers come out you go
no it's the one i want yeah
he's a fun guy everybody i don't know
what to tell you hey talk to my agent
toby i don't know what to tell you yeah
my agent does all the numbers okay
his name's hans supposed to be in here
today
all right guys so as you as you know
when you join a patreon we will answer
your garbage question
and i gotta tell you there's been some
humdingers some home runs some grand
slams
some deep fly balls to right field where
the guy can't get i got it
a couple of errors that'd be your
nickname
the next uh this one is from ed
[Applause]
were you or did you know a kid that
could flip his eyelids inside out oh
yeah you could do it i could do it oh
let's see give it a whirl now i got
contacts and [ __ ] i can't do it now yeah
that's the excuse i poured my hamstring
when i was in like taking an asthma
attack when in a game i've done that all
right i couldn't do it but we see i knew
it hey you would have thrown that in my
face when i the day i met you hey it was
age fully flipped my eyelids if i could
if i could do that i would just have
them up all the time sure be kidding me
freaking people out even more
hey ladies
i'd wear sunglasses and then take them
off oh what was it
[Laughter]
ah you stink hey gang let's talk about
ladder ladder ladder with the rising
cost of living the world is a
topsy-turvy place right now you got
student debt you're trying to buy a
house you don't want to leave your kids
or partner with a huge financial burden
that's why ladder is the best ladder is
100 digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for 3 million
in coverage or less all you need is a
few minutes a phone a laptop to apply
online ladder smart smart algorithms
work in real time so you find out if
you're instantly approved if you want to
talk to a person you can their team of
licensed agents doesn't work on
commission so they're not going to
upsell you they're just going to help
you no hidden fees you can cancel any
time get a refu full refund if you
change your mind in the first 30 days so
go to ladderlife.com garbage today if
you see to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
mint mobile mint mobile mint mobile the
best in the biz if you're trying to save
some money mint mobile has your back why
are you still paying insane amounts
every month for wireless switch to mint
mobile it's the easiest way to save some
cash
it's the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only mint mobile
lets you maximize your savings with its
plan starting at just 15
a month uh my guys my wife the foreign
investor has been using it for years
it's easy peasy no long-term contracts
they send it right to your door
uh by going online and eliminating
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes the significant savings on to you
so you choose use your own phone with
mint mobile you get to keep your same
number along with all your existing
contacts it's easy peasy just do it to
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get that plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com garbage do it uh
i couldn't do it my buddy matt could do
it i think it's a listener growing up he
could do that he could make himself fart
that's awesome that's awesome you know
anybody with webbed toes
we had a kid with webbed toes
yeah
his name was mike real weird i wasn't
friends with the x-men in high school
all my boys went full term i don't know
what they dude
[Laughter]
you got a couple of soft cookies in your
batch it was a little undercooked
yikes hey put this one back in the oven
throw the microwave for a minute i i
tried the broiler the the eyelid
flipping thing was obviously [ __ ]
huge at a certain time
that all that stuff hit when you were
like 12 when it was just like being
weird double jointed the gleaking we've
talked about that all that kind of stuff
the spit down it almost touches and it
comes back up i tried to do the eyelid
thing once i really wanted to be that
guy
you know the kid that could that would
just do all that [ __ ] at like a bar
mitzvah or a party and just kill yeah i
tried it once and i did it and i [ __ ]
freaked out because i couldn't get it to
flip back
they're raining upstairs mm-hmm
she stopped oh my god i almost ended up
in the emergency room my mom's being a
nerd my mom tells the story her uh my
uncle
my uncle dan got in a fight at like the
playground they were like kids or
whatever you know in the city and uh he
got beat up or hit really hard
and his eye was all [ __ ] up like swell
you know whatever he got sucked in the
eye or something and uh dudes in the
middle of night or they were like going
to bed and he sneezed and it popped out
of its socket and he he grabbed my mom
like is everything all right i was like
ah
had to rush into the hospital
beetlejuice
what the [ __ ]
talk about scaring you for a lot dude
every sneeze would scare me for the rest
of your life
[ __ ] your eye pops out one sneeze
when you're 11.
no way out
yeah i i never i never had any
of those weird uh
you weren't that kid you couldn't do
anything i got nothing no not double
jointed what about this thing
never farts never never i can't could
you could you make the water come out of
your thing like that a little bit but
not cool not you know nothing nothing to
draw a crowd
nothing to write home about you know
what i mean we're not passing the bucket
around there uh-huh um i couldn't do i
can't whistle i can't wink my left eye
i can only do try to wink your left eye
it's bad go ahead you're gonna think i'm
[ __ ] with you yeah go ahead my wife i
did all right that's that one uh-huh
i swear to god that's me trying ready
holy colombo
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i swear to god dude that's me trying to
wink my left eye yeah do it again all
right right eye the alien's taking over
kevin's body
go ahead wash over water
ready
hey glee welcome to earth
yikes dude i don't even know what you're
doing
i genuine
[Laughter]
i lean into it like that's like the
momentum's gonna give it something i
can't do it i can't whistle i can't do
[ __ ] man jesus christ that is what your
eyes keep crossing this is your mouth
yeah you turn into jerry lewis
lady
what the [ __ ] was that ah no no dude
my wife will just i'll she'll like make
me do it and just laugh in my face for
an hour i genuinely can't do it
all right ready yeah really really
really really good really try to go if
you're listening to this i'd recommend
getting over the old youtube
and check out this little pizza
all right ready
don't move your mouth don't worry having
a stroke
taking his shirt off
[Laughter]
when i was a baby or something
i can't do it i could do left eye and
right eye boom boom
that's it that's like the face a baby
makes when you put a thermometer in its
ass
are you doing that i don't know
what's going on in queens
when would you have seen that yeah you
don't even have kids you don't have any
nieces or nephews or anything what kind
of tic-tacs are you watching
for research purposes
yikes oh yeah i got nothing man i got no
no no no nothing like that cool who the
[ __ ] had webbed feet this kid mike
good swimmer not real that was the big
joke no at least i saw him at the pool
where like it was just between his big
toe and his middle you know the pointer
finger toe
and it was just like you know maybe it
didn't go all the way up like it wasn't
like we would have burned him in
bluebell i think he said he cut it and
it grew like it like reconnected that's
even weirder yeah
half salamander hey power line pete
relax will you dude get out of here with
that
you [ __ ] cook you up at the stake for
that yeah
that's true dude i mean if he was born
like 30 years earlier they might have
[ __ ] oh throwing him off a cliff or
something right in the dumpster
it's like [ __ ] 300.
toss them in the recyclables we're going
to lunch funny yikes yeah
good question great question eddie
loved it uh this is from craig and we've
talked about this first time long time
ever go magnet fishing no i just wrote
that down as a question oh [ __ ] god
damn it
real trashy yeah i love it though i love
it those instagram videos
[ __ ] sign me up usually it's a wrench
it is then you find some gun that killed
[ __ ]
johnny button eyes or something they
found them they found them yeah they
find guns yeah they just could call the
gobstone i saw i just saw one that they
wouldn't go doing that [ __ ] over the
gowanus or anything out in brooklyn for
anybody out there listening
let sleeping dogs lie
yeah don't do that no
i hate to break it to you they fake a
lot of those videos
sons of [ __ ] is anything real what
about those pranks in walmart and [ __ ]
like that they're not fake right a lot
of uh it's it depends you like anytime
there's like a guy anytime a hot chick
is involved it's fake there should be a
rule against that the ufo videos too
i could sometimes go down a uh you know
a ufo video rabbit hole on uh instagram
and you know it's fake
it's like why are people such [ __ ]
nerds
they're clouding it up with the real
ones
if there may be some is it yeah
i'm not an alien this is what you guys
talk about at your [ __ ] monthly
meetups
ufo anonymous or whatever
why would you be anonymous i don't know
but they don't want girls knowing so the
government doesn't come and get you like
randy quaid
yeah i hate that [ __ ] drives me nuts
uh fake videos yeah uh all right this
one's from diane ten dollar home ten
dollar homet that's a new one homies and
homets really nice what that must object
homie is universal okay homie's gender
uh no non-gender or all gender and it
covers every anything and anyone okay
all right 10. ten dollar homie florida's
really rubbing off on him jesus christ
um
no opposite opposite inclusive inclusive
hey i'm one of the good guys
pelosi
[Music]
i like the helmets
she's got a nice ring to it that's all
i'm saying listen if you want to call
yourself a homemade you can call
yourself a homemaker yourself anything
you want yeah just don't call me
looking for money
uh this is from diane never had a
question read
um despite multiple attempts coming at
the whoa throwing a little thrown a
little [ __ ] flare at me that's right
dude you don't take any [ __ ] off
uh i was too busy buying cool jackets is
it garbage to wave in a car exactly like
yours that's the jeep thing bias
i would do it i would do it in my lumina
as a kid for fun like i was like 16 17.
yeah sure you know having fun with the
buddies sure everybody's all high or
whatever yeah coupling a couple of
heaters you know i gotcha you see an old
i think it's cool if you're doing it
with it you can't be doing it with a
corolla or something
but like at the time it had a 96 chevy
lumina and not many of them in a row not
many of them on the road and if there
was mandalorians you got to say hi they
were all
they were all old folk you know what i
mean they were all like
blue hairs where it's just like two you
just see you know a a puff of hair and
they waved back no they didn't know off
the road baldy get out of my way little
dick they didn't know what was happening
i well documented
about the jeep thing the jeep wait but
that's only right
yeah grown men
that's [ __ ] lame i
uh
roll around in the latitude with the
attitude and happened to pull up to
captain chucky's maybe like a month ago
or two months ago when i was home
and a girl pulled in with the exact same
car as me what's up ladies
is that in your mom's name
i
made a fool of myself
um
because she thought i was like yelling
at her
because like she was parking too close
to me or something like well why did she
think she you were yelling at her was
there were you
i was i was going like oh [ __ ]
and she was like what and she got out i
was like we got the same car oh my god
guberville
we got the same car just picking up four
pounds of shrimp
don't tell my mom this isn't making it
home
holy
figure there's some captain chuckies for
me and my dad i love you buddy oh man
that was as bad remember in the remember
in the you complimented that lady's
purse that one time
[ __ ]
remember in the elevator in like
indianapolis or something you're like i
like your purse i was like holy [ __ ]
we're going to [ __ ]
this is
that was weird the whole town dried up
yeah i was just being nice
i know but you're weird also at times i
was standing behind you in an elevator
at the time with two other goons and it
went around me
i hate your purse
is that genuine leather
i believe he said genuine genuine
leather
yeah i got a couple of those made a fool
myself a time or two not gonna lie yeah
yeah
never with the cars again
never again yeah that's probably why i
don't like it because i tried it once
and it backfired
yeah it's not for me
[ __ ]
ruined my captain chucky shout out to
captain chucky's makes the hell of a key
lime pie that sounds i i get to you i'm
not saying it's not i'm not saying it's
not good i never had i don't know you
you you know you fresh seafood you know
your food and you crab cakes lobster
biscuits plus they have a wide variety
of frozen selections it sounds so trashy
captain chucky's it's just like sounds
like oh it's not captain it's captain oh
it's captain yeah clap and chucky's yeah
cause he likes to party
it's not formal also the the nearest
ocean is about 158 miles away
captain of the schuylkill river maybe
i love a good shrimp cocktail they're
magna fishing for the [ __ ] clams
yeah magnet fishing take a hike with
that
once you find a safe with some cash in
it
yeah i just saw them when they found a
safe pulled it up and then it was empty
inside
yeah who's throwing away a full safe
i don't know is that what you're saying
is fake t-bone yeah dude what are they
throwing the safe over then pulling it i
mean because they're really pulling it
out yeah
yeah dude no there you go yeah that
makes sense as a guy who makes videos
for the internet that does make sense
what are you how would you get all the
barnacles
your channel is based on you finding
random cool [ __ ] in a river you find
cool [ __ ] in a river yeah you might need
to keep yeah dude i mean come on i got a
mermaid dude
this is my 37th video where ain't found
[ __ ] thanks for subscribing yeah i'll be
at i'm gonna you know hopefully we get
some tomorrow
seven views
yeah well there's that one couple that
does it and it funds their travel around
the around the world they're living in a
van or something like that that sounds
like it's going great for them well it's
like a young adventurous couple rolling
with that you [ __ ]
they're nice people
yeah so they got to be catching
something but here's my thing with that
nice adventurous couples and vans
traveling the country you always know
how that ends they're they're you're in
europe though european they go down like
uh malta and
all that [ __ ] the maldives no not the
maldives that's where the bozos go
um you thought it was lettuce last week
by the way still think it is uh
let me ask you this i'm here is it wrong
yes is it immoral maybe if
you're one of those guys that goes
around with your uh
metal detector on the beach finding
people's like old engagement rings and
all that kind of stuff is it a little
[ __ ] up to keep that stuff i mean what
are you gonna like what are you gonna
what are you gonna do well if it says
too tammy love johnny i mean yeah i
think you post it i think they try yeah
me i'm sure a little bit but like i mean
how many times does jewelry say two
tammy from tommy you know all right this
one's from ducky don't know if that's
his government name oh that's a [ __ ]
sweet name i told you my neighbor
growing up was ducky ducky weird guy we
had a duck as you know growing up yeah
my cousin cousin cousin duck cousin duck
yeah the duck it was the duck flo
eddie mugabe and ziggy they're the four
brothers jesus yeah great nick eddie
mugabe eddie mugabe yeah he's going to
run into him in a [ __ ] dark alley
that guy can't run fast but he does
shoot straight
he's got a steady steady itchy trigger
finger but ducky's great
i knew yeah ducky was my neighbor real
he worked for like nasa but it didn't
make sense because at least that's
he called me peeking you know how he had
like those windows
the theory in the neighborhood was he
was building a spaceship in his basement
that was no that's a disney movie you'd
watch
that was the running theory and i was
always thinking how the [ __ ] he gonna
get it out of there
you know what i mean you built a
full-size spaceship in a basement
you fat idiot
that's [ __ ] awesome but that's what
the kids were always clamoring that you
know ducky was building a spaceship he
worked in like aeronautics or something
but i don't know where
he's just working on some sex swing
[Laughter]
she's upside down in that
he must be testing the g-force or
something
it must be anti-gravity in that basement
because other four guys must all be
scientists
they could take their clothes off for
aerodynamics
again we're closing space what are you
doing
yeah everybody knows that yeah he was
building a spaceship in his basement
i mean we you know he was weird his car
talked to him like knight rider-esque i
swear to god it was a blue he was really
indicative of the radio dummy no it was
really i'm telling you man it was like a
blue
[ __ ] trans am looking but it wasn't a
trans am but like one of those like you
know
like firebird like boxy [ __ ]
delorean type [ __ ] looking cars okay
you just
named five different models of cars i
know but you know what i mean like one
of those like [ __ ] like firebird was
unboxy it was sleek and sexy not the
older one i feel like the older ones had
that like [ __ ] the knight rider car
that wasn't boxy that wasn't round
it was aerodynamic it was sleek
yeah but i'm not i'm saying like with
the you're taking boxy wrong it wasn't
like a buick i'm not saying that okay
the [ __ ] yeah like aerodynamic but
that was all like angles
the cars weren't rounded off back then
how they are now you know what i mean
yeah it was like
you see what i'm saying no
i can tell you're no ducky i could tell
you that i'm not i've
i doubt his cart talked it's probably
his alarm me i'm telling you man he
would turn it on it would go hello ducky
like he wanted to be [ __ ] night rider
sure one of his buddies wasn't some nerd
wasn't sitting in the passengers i mean
yeah maybe if he was trying to fool the
eight-year-old in the neighborhood sure
he got me i don't know his car talked to
him that's all i [ __ ] know he tried
everything with you and he was built
yeah let's talk about adam and eve adam
and eve one more time so they hear you
in the back adam and eve you know what
adam and eve is but if you don't they
help you with sex sexy time baby who
wants better snacks everybody does what
are we doing here and adam and eve is
the best way to get started is by going
to adam.com right now is offering 50 off
just about any item that's insane
they're giving the place away over there
at adam and eve more than that adam and
eve wants to make your life easy they
offer discreet shipping
uh as your privacy is a priority plus
free shipping on your entire order so
you don't want the neighbors snooping
around your packages or anything like
that you bring more pleasure and
satisfaction into the bedroom which we
all want doesn't matter how much you
spend or what you buy
all will be packaged and sent discreetly
for free go to adamandeve.com select any
one item it could be adventurous new toy
or anything you desire just enter offer
code garbage at checkout and you'll get
50
off almost any item
uh when you do this you also get free
shipping if you go off your entire order
when you enter the code garbage that's
garbage at g-a-r-b-a-g-e
at adamandeve.com this is exclusive
offer specific for this podcast so be
sure to use the code garbage to get you
not just the discount but also 100
free shipping do it code garbage
and he caught you what wait was he an
adult yeah he was a man did he have kids
no kids him and his wife no kids and
they would have volleyball parties in
the in the [ __ ] summer they'd set up
like a net and play in their backyard
against each other like there'd be like
five or six couples come over and now as
i'm saying it that's a swingers party
yeah you're goddamn right they didn't
even realize that yeah yeah we would i
remember we'd be like who the [ __ ] plays
volleyball in their backyard shoot some
hoops you know is that were they right
next to you yeah
so isn't that weird because we have a
fence in our backyard
but you don't have a fence no so isn't
it weird when you're just out there on
some [ __ ] saturday no pool
[ __ ] sitting outside and the
neighbors are having like a party right
next to you
i mean i was eight
but like didn't you want to go over
there and hang out are they leaving the
weirdos who were building spaceships and
playing volleyball nah i'm good you guys
are getting laid though yeah i mean no
it's an eight-year-old who the [ __ ]
wants to go play with like 35 year olds
guess you're right
i think it's just strange like right
next to you is a party
yeah i mean i see what you're saying but
like i also just wouldn't stand like if
i didn't have a pool if there was
nothing going on in my backyard i wasn't
just [ __ ] standing out there like a
[ __ ] goober i was working on my
winking
um but he caught me peeking in his
windows you know how they have those
what the [ __ ]
where you know how they have like the
kind of the small windows in the
basement yeah the basement windows well
me and a couple of the neighborhood guys
got together like down down on the
ground by where the hoses yeah yeah yeah
yeah we used to sneak into that thing
like yeah of course [ __ ] stella 13.
excuse me sir i'm with the cia the
children investigation
i'm gonna need to see some permits for
this for the spaceship
if i have to come back here it's your
ass ducky how was mrs ducky
looking back type out like you know fit
woman to poof like kind of like uh where
was there like the peg
nasa compound that's what i'm saying
bucks county
there clearly wasn't there was a
lockheed martin maybe he worked there as
i put that together start keeping my
mouth shut yeah could be working for
skunk works that's kelly johnson's
outfit i'm still on kippy's a little
kippy as a detective well of course
bluebell pennsylvania is the perfect
place to hide
no one you want to be an alien you want
to go in no one's working i love my lisp
in this reality hey ducky one
[Laughter]
he's
more
wife a [ __ ] by any chance drinking
apple juice out of a coffee mug i'm so
i'm smoking
get a light duck
he walks he walks down the basement i'm
in there one of you bums got a light
what are you doing in here uh you're
right back door was open
but he caught me and one more thing
you're at a peanut butter he caught me
peeking me and a couple other kids
peeking in the window we were trying to
get to the bottom of this [ __ ]
spaceship you know i was saying there's
clearly no spaceship
but you know was there
no i never saw one but there was like a
lot of what did he say when he caught
you
nothing he just put up like tin foil so
you couldn't see in the basement anymore
what yeah ooh and this was like
coneheads had just hit you know that was
we were like big into like what the
[ __ ] cooking down there let me know if
i gotta
you know if i could if i could defend
the cul-de-sac i'm reading willing and
able you know it's calm he's building a
rocket next i know
um
he didn't come out and say hey what are
you guys doing no he didn't how do you
know he saw you
because we were like oh [ __ ] did he we
rolled we rolled outside of the field of
vision and like oh [ __ ] did he see us
and then the next day there was [ __ ] the
window was covered tin foil something
along those lines something real nasty
man like that's [ __ ] shaky yeah
that's what i'm saying probably put a
chip in you
buy your head so big
what because they were bigger back then
like computers
so they had
i had to make my head bigger to fit the
big chip yeah okay
things are i mean you got me dead the
rights on the logo becky's probably
working your controls from his basement
right now
i am ducky
um we did that same thing one time at a
uh how did this come up
how did what come up that question how
did we get there ducky you activated the
chip in your head
we snuck over to somebody's some girl's
house in the middle of the night and we
he was she she was supposed to come out
when we got there
and we were like waiting by that
basement window and her dad was
downstairs drinking
right okay and we're sitting there and
we're just sitting there watching this
grown man just get hammered in his
basement at like two o'clock in the
morning on a friday goes over to the
humidifier and just pees in the
humidifier i don't in the humidifier the
humidity was it on i don't know it
wasn't couldn't be weird if he was
[ __ ] getting high on his own supply
but he peed into the tank of the
humidifier yeah i would assume it was a
dehumidifier i guess in the basement
yeah dehumidifier yeah dehumidifier
we got one cooking now that you just
gotta we have to have we have to run a
dehumidifier in the basement at all
times really takes so much water out of
the air to just to you know
so it's more similar to your alien
atmosphere
wait i'm an alien now yeah kinda
okay still playing around with it you're
working out the plot twist in this one
are they still your neighbor no no no no
they left the rocket ship yeah of course
yeah
blessed in the middle of the night
the roof came right off
where did he move to
um i don't know
i mean dude do you think do you think
denise is keeping in touch with a guy
named ducky who's you know playing
volleyball in the backyard she's doing
my going away party hey buddy get the
[ __ ] out she's in the window staring and
blessing herself i know
i know yeah looking at them knowingly
they're all going to go inside and have
an orgy [ __ ] dirt bags yeah
she's just stuck over there dealing with
you
[ __ ] play-doh in your hair
dog [ __ ] on the carpet
i can thumb up your ass
man i can't believe he didn't die me out
he didn't yeah they weren't they never
listen we grew we we grew up all uh
all like there was like 10 houses were
built my street and everybody moved in
at the same time
they then moved in once the first person
moved out so they and they never
ingratiated themselves you know like
these 10 families all moved into the
the street at the same time so everybody
knew each other sure you know like the
kids were all the same age we're all it
was just like you know one big community
little jaunt right and then they moved
in and [ __ ] never ingratiated
themselves in the [ __ ] thing so
everybody was like good riddance you
know man maybe he did work for nasa
that's all adding up did he ever
was his car his or was it like a
government car
the one that talked to him
was his well that was ducky's personal
car what did he take day to day though
did he take like a late model plymouth i
don't remember what it was but that was
part of the guy's an e.t yeah dude kippy
this guy's good yeah
the spaceship wasn't in the house the
car
was the spaceship you [ __ ] idiot
talking yeah now he's probably over
there in russia with putin
why would you take a spaceship to russia
commercial flights go daily yeah but he
can't take the car there what he's
working for the other side
they pulled the wool right over your
eyes where to let your country down
baldi
they're gonna have your badge in your
gun over there
god damn it
put your rolling your cheese sticks on
the table
get out of my sight
gonna need your butter roll and your cap
gun
you're on desk duty
two weeks no waffles
man love the [ __ ] frozen waffles okay
i would come back from school when there
was nothing real and i would make
waffles just no syrup just waffles and
probably a can of coke or something just
dry waffles eat dry eggos and a can of
coke maybe a little peanut butter or
something on them
watch it a little judge duty
now drl was big at that time
so i would call in and try to talk to
carson
i'm kidding is you i'm kidding yeah you
know you weren't
you know you got three phones going
it's like hello hold up one second i'm
just requesting britney spears videos
trying to get my wanker to wail on
myself
i'd like to see lucky one more time can
you play it back to back before 4 15 if
possible how about toxic but followed
with a lucky
in slow motion and then bye bye bye if
you don't mind
those nsync boys had tight little mods
275 calls finally got through
couldn't speak mouthful waffles
excuse me sir what are you saying
[Laughter]
my neighbors will call me
oh god
ever go to trl
dude i my family
has been in new york twice have you ever
been in a not the time that you guys
went to wherever the [ __ ] you went to up
here when you went to the view or
whatever you did but as a kid a studio
audience yeah
yeah because i was i was in that was in
double there
which i've mentioned yeah my boy steve
pyle won the whole thing won the race
car told this televised
no it was an old radio show yeah you
[ __ ] pinhead it was televised it was
the first season of double dare
well we should be able to find it if you
probably weren't even born yet
maybe it was around 86 87.
yeah then maybe i was born tough guy
yeah you were you're i was sitting i was
sitting there making fast [ __ ] went back
in time and killed you i was probably 18
months making fat jokes hey look at that
fat little [ __ ] in the second row no i
was thinking and eating his nose i was
in the back i couldn't afford the two he
couldn't afford the nice seats
back there in the cheap seats who's i'll
take twos
staying out front of some [ __ ]
warehouse no but i didn't get picked to
be on the show and it hurt me deeply
would it fit down the slide what were
you talking
i guess i didn't think i had what it
takes to be on tv you
don't
let's not start okay i'm sorry i didn't
realize that
i was just disagreeing with you
apparently i don't
i can take it for comedy purposes yeah i
think i had it they lined us all up and
they went and one two three
pick
i knew what was going on too and i
really really wanted it that's why it
was gonna be my big break i can sense it
on you have like a suit on and
everything everyone's making fun of
sunglasses
ordering a double [ __ ] macchiato
yelling at somebody
i brought my own slime
just boogers
i've been saving up for months
slime was huge
you were too old when gak dropped
remember gak
gak and phloem
phloem was all right i don't think we're
talking about the same thing
yeah it's plenty of gas no gak was like
the wet like mushy and then phloem was
like a bunch of little beads stuck
together with like color
why were you playing with it my cousins
played with it i had younger cousins
i know what gak is doesn't check the
beady stuff no that's floam i just said
i'm cool i swear
i love mighty ducks
slime the original slime was all right
you can get it in the little uh
things in front of the grocery store for
a nickel and then you'd ruin the
interior of your dad's jeep
that you know what you get thrown out of
a sizzler you know what i was [ __ ]
surgical with too
hold on stop
the long sticky hand that you would
throw i had i had an orange one that was
like my sniper rifle dude
[Laughter]
okay kids pop quiz you looking for this
yeah i could take an eyelash off yo bam
real quick you didn't see it coming i
was hitting my dog and [ __ ] i was
[ __ ] i was tight that thing was
something else all you had to do was
wash it with a little soap and water it
was like brand new same thing with those
little octopuses that walk down the wall
we never had those you don't remember
them they came in uh cereal boxes like
cocoa puffs and stuff you'd throw it up
against the wall and it would slowly
walk down
love that [ __ ]
i used to love looking through the
cereal box for a little toy before
school they used to give out legit [ __ ]
like they used to give out actual like
cars like that would be at the bottom of
those things
so you bit one
crack a tooth yeah now it's all [ __ ]
i never really got into it it seemed
real cracker jackie to me i would love
to take one of those things
i'm telling you i was good i had an
orange one or yell like gold yeah those
things were all right
shut up yeah i was [ __ ] feel like a
mob boss
you want a fresh one
[Laughter]
hit you from across the room i don't
even need to be next to you oh man
that's good stuff
um stop me if we talked about this we
talked about something similar i think
we talked about the pepper and the beer
yes one up like this yes we did
everything
people put pepper in the beer to keep
the head this one this is from quinn you
or anyone you know sprinkle salt on the
napkin at a restaurant before setting
your drink down
why so the napkin doesn't stick yes
i think those little i i did some
research into this because i didn't get
it those little like thin bar napkins
like so you go up to a vault like a dive
bar and then you know they don't give
you a close-up they throw the napkin
sure put your beer on that that starts
sweating it like that gets wet and
becomes like [ __ ] you know wet paper
at the bottom apparently if you sprinkle
some salt on it it's kind of
gentleman-esque you sit it on that and
that stay the salt absorbs the water
rather than the thing
have you done that or do you know people
that have done that i've never seen
anybody done that's real barfly [ __ ] i
like it though i've been in a few
saloons with some rough customers threw
a little salt down yeah i like that
that's cool to me but it gets all over
the bar he's got to wait who has salt on
the bar do you have to say excuse me can
i have some salt that's unless you bring
your own you know whatever that's weird
that's weird that's a conversation
starter some bars will have the like
like the setups with like the ketchup
and the yeah that'll be in like the
thing like every like four seats or
whatever i don't know i'm just saying
these are old-time bars it seems like a
lot i always like when the when the
napkin sticks because it's like a
little ready-made thing you don't got to
worry about it just
put it down okay i don't care if i have
a
i guess some people are a little more
particular than you you know
maybe kevin
maybe
sure this one's a home run sam ever had
joint bank accounts with your girlfriend
no
that's bad you're getting in financial
girlfriend
yeah not a wife not a fiance
me and my wife don't even have joint
accounts nice
yeah
you're dead weight to her i know she
wouldn't allow it she's like i'm not
letting the [ __ ] irs get their
fingers you know whatever mess you've
gotten into come back and bite me in the
ass
no thank you yeah t-bone never no way
how many relationships i've ever been in
that that level of serious it was a it
was like it was like holy [ __ ] it was
like you don't ask i don't ask we don't
ask nobody knows yeah yeah yeah i don't
know what you got you don't know what i
got
yeah we're chilling yeah i um i knew
what they got i knew what they had
never much
sure but i'm sure you were tap dancing
about what you got
uh no i was always pretty open and
honest about that
takes a village to raise a foley yeah
ah
[ __ ]
someone in my family
someone in my family
i had someone in my family who you know
might have dabbled in some
extracurricular activities
like maritally no
okay substance wise okay at partaking or
distributing
mucho partaking partaking to the point
where it was okay way past weekend well
that's more charming that's innocent um
hey honey we had five grand in the
account on friday now there's a dead
hooker what's the deal sure no but it
was that so
they were talking sh
she was in a relationship with a guy
uh-huh
who was also you know suffering or
struggling with addiction or you know
this is abrupt paulie partying too much
yeah and uh
i remember that we were at christmas or
something and she was like yeah things
are going well we're going to move to
florida and i was like whoo that's not
[ __ ] good that is never a good day
doing that and it's like i grew up with
a lot of drug addict couples sure right
like a lot of my friends and like you
know people like acquaintances all like
exclusively they all became like you
know they weren't couples and then they
were spending so much time together
because they were drug addicted couples
a tough look the toughest and she goes
yeah things are going we're going to
move the
my mom doesn't know my mom didn't know
that how bad it was but i'm looking i'm
going oh you guys are [ __ ]
you're barely keeping this get closer to
south america that's never a good sign
but my mom was just like oh yeah maybe
you know maybe they smoke weed or do
adderall or something like my mom
doesn't i remember the one time you hit
it with the orange thing
i'm brought down
she's going through your purse right now
which she did she stole td gift cards
out of my mom's purse you catch your
hand going in
it's my brothers
oh man i like this thing we gotta get
one of these
we gotta get one all over
a family acquaintance or whatever she
was like smoking smoking weed she got
more track marks in the eastern railroad
what are you talking about this this
girl i was in college and so is she and
dude her teeth are falling out of her
face she's like full blown in the throes
of proper drug addiction my mom goes i
was like did you see [ __ ] did you see
heather god damn my mom's like i think
she's doing adderall i'm an adderall
adderall gets you [ __ ] you take adderall
to study for a test this dog's doing at
her all
hey honey she ain't behind on her finals
all right this ain't cbd we're talking
about
she's blowing for tricks down at the
docks what do you think
i
but tip your makeup a little bit kip
yeah sorry um
yeah i remember how we got there
oh no the bank account and she was like
we're we're going to move to florida
we're like oh good you know cool yeah
you know and she was like
we just got to get a bank account and
she took the turkey bones
[Laughter]
she was like we just got to get a bank
account and i was like oh my god how old
are you i'm in college so we're all the
same age i was in my 20s we just got to
get a bank i'm like
there's no way you got two forms of
id know you don't know where your social
security card is and i got i'm gonna put
money on it you ain't got a goddamn
passport either
[Laughter]
ah it's a good piece of business
yeah
how's she doing now
okay uh yeah i'm not i'm not sure
there's certain sections of my family
it's ext obviously very extended family
and the you know we don't always cross
paths
okay
since here at the florida shows
you think you didn't come to tampa
i probably honestly i wouldn't even
recognize her if i saw her
really yeah we had very little
interaction when we were younger that's
it okay and then like you know kids or
whatever and then
my mom would stay in touch with that
side of the family and stuff like that i
don't mean to make light of it obviously
no of course i mean you know like i've
said i had a lot of friends who struggle
with addiction still do it's very tough
sure
um i just wanna sit across from you
that's very true and one sitting over
there in the car jesus christ oh that's
right he's got to learn how to handle
your [ __ ]
a couple of bubble gummers in here all
right a couple of weekenders hey buddy
you want to go pro get a jacket all
right
i'm so mad right now oh no no no i was
just thinking that's the thing about
real pros is that you pull your knees
out you gotta retire early dog yeah bo
jackson ran so hard he pulled his hips
out of his socket yeah
yeah me too
[Laughter]
bo jackson also pulled my hips out of my
socket i beat him on a bag i got drunk
i just i tried to sell him 0.8
he wasn't buying it
that truck and ran my mouth at an after
party
good stuff great good
the jacket's nice this is the best one
by far got it tailored too it came real
big really got a tailor tailored uh-huh
they must have laughed at you oh it's
just his boy taylor hooks up jack
i cut it right down the middle for you
dude
no the lady was like oh this is nice
jeff very old jacket very nice
yeah
they're so they're vint i'm buying them
all vintage there's a couple of new ones
but they're all vintage so the sizes are
all wonky they're like oh this is an xl
and then it's like [ __ ] huge or it's
really small
vintage might be a strong word do you
concur mr mcmullen nah it looks like it
smells like a dart league hey yes it
smells like a bullseye
all right that's the jacket talking now
throw rocks tonight kippy
look out
hey kj's here
hippie did the first half kj's gonna
close her out
also i've been posting all the pictures
of the jackets on instagram going like
can't stop won't stop like whatever dude
the comments from the [ __ ] bozos and
the homies are so [ __ ] fun it's a
good time it's great um all right let's
see here let's do a couple more then we
gotta rip it up
this one has the big man written
all over it this is from sous chef
boyardee home run of a name fantastic uh
ever use a hairbrush as a back scratcher
have i
i've used a hairbrush as a [ __ ] ball
scratcher and let me tell you something
you want to talk about entering the
gates of valhalla
yeah
a [ __ ] what kind of brush i go like
you know the wooden ones that have the
they have the the thing with the little
white tips on them or whatever sure yeah
they're my mine are black and you know
compresses a little bit yeah they tell
you something i can you sit maternity
style on the couch buck naked eternity
stop with your legs up like you're about
to deliver a baby and you just get in
there
whose brush is this is your your lady's
brush oh it's my brush it was my brush
this is years ago
you burn that thing
okay it's my brush it's the brush that i
have now it wasn't that and you use it
on your head
obviously
yeah i rinse it off sure
but i've recently discovered the joys of
scratching the taint
it's almost orgasmic what do you mean
scratching in between the gooch i know
what the taint is but what do you mean
scrat like d right you're saying you're
going to have an ice cream yeah or
you're just like i'm going to get my
daily stretches it get started yeah get
started before there's an itch or just
kind of a little itch and then you get
down there and then everything starts
itching and you just
that's pretty good today you take a big
whiff after that
sure you know you do a flyby you buzz
the tower
but the best is in the shower my shower
brush that i have
[ __ ] go in there
your eyes roll in the back of your head
feels so good
it almost feels like you're about to uh
it's what it feels like it's a family
show we do here this is like mighty duck
seven we're doing you're talking about
using a [ __ ] shower well you're
asking me the hard-hitting question
clean your gooch it started off as a
back scratcher you immediately took it
to your no-nos i like a fork on my back
but i now have a brush that we got from
sephora that exfoliates so i get
scratched down i'm trying to exfoliate
you know what i mean
get rid of you oh that's pretty cool
that was kevin not the jacket yeah don't
blame the jacket on that one jacket's
gonna have a word with you when you get
out of here did you ever know anybody
that had those things
they were like square things metal and
you could put your hand in it all your
spencers had those yeah one one kid we
were never allowed to buy them no i
think i think my buddy might have had
one i think pat might have one maybe
what about the spaceship that like those
things that you put on your desk like
the balls that would go back and forth
or like the thing that
would that was all stuff that like what
no that was like stuff lawyers would
have her
last time the ryans aren't buying that
stuff the brain teasers and [ __ ] no way
spending [ __ ] bernie money on [ __ ]
brain teasers those ball things were
pretty cool though they snapped
back yeah that was like what a judge
would have or something
small claims court obviously he's not
handling the big cases
uh all right let's wrap it up we gotta
wrap up all right gang listen we [ __ ]
love you to death come see a live show
see you on a road see you on the road
support the patreon support the patriots
guys i know
also there's obviously we're gaining new
listeners and stuff every every week
every month every episode whatever we
appreciate it we appreciate all the
support i i can't express the amount of
high quality content that's on the
patreon honestly i mean there's
almost a year and a half or you know 15
months of weekly episodes of hard
feelings that's just me and the big man
and t-bone you know no guess but just
real [ __ ] you're laughing at all
right
we really pull the curtain we get in
arguments it's like an hr meeting for
the team you think we're a piece of [ __ ]
here what do you see my patreon
yeah thank you so much for everything if
you've ever just watched the show shared
the show anything uh we [ __ ] love you
thank you love your death and we'll see
you next week peace